Hey youtubers, it’s charlie and the moment
is finally here.
Game of Thrones finally posted their first
full season 4 trailer.
We also found out that episode 1 will premiere
april 6.
Which is pretty close to when season 3 premiered
last year.
Season 4 is going to be a little different
from previous seasons in that it’s going
to change even more things from the books.
So this video will be a detailed breakdown
of everything we see in the trailer.
I’ll also be doing a game of thrones q&a
video tomorrow night, subscribe to get it
and post any questions about season 4 you
want me to include.
Careful for spoilers.
I tried not to go too deep into what happens
outside of the scenes we see in the trailer.
Time for dragons, let’s do this -
1 - The trailer opens to a shot of a dragon
flying over kings landing.
We only see the shadow, but chronologically
where things are in the books, none of the
dragons have left the east.
So if one does fly near the red keep it would
be a huge departure from canon.
2 - Look at the wingspan of the dragon.
It’s huge now.
It almost looks like they’re jumping forward
in the story several months.
The dragons grow very fast in the books, but
drogon, the biggest isn’t this large until
dance with dragons.
So assume that season 4 will include aspects
of book 5.
3 - The purple wedding feast.
This is the red wedding level event of season
4.
I won’t spoil what happens, but the voice
over from Jaime talks about how the people
love their king.
Which is a play on the notion that everyone
wants Joffrey dead.
They’re referring to the war against stannis
and the battle of blackwater.
In reality it was tyrion that saved the city.
There have been a lot of behind the scenes
pictures of the set when they filmed these
scenes.
They had more extras on camera during the
purple wedding and the feast than in any other
episode with exception to the season 1 premiere.
4 - A feast for crows.
The crow is very symbolic to a song of ice
and fire, but visually in the trailer it’s
a reference to book 4 a feast for crows.
It’s the idea that the dead are starting
to pile up.
5 - Daeneriss and ser friendzone start to
march their army to Mereen.
It’s the next major conflict and right now
we don’t know how much of that plot season
4 will include.
Her story is relatively static once she gets
there.
So they would have to depart from the book
plot a lot to move her around more.
6 - The charger barreling down daeneriss is
possibly one of the sons of the harpy one
of the mercenary bands in mereen.
7 - The new daario.
the actor playing daario was recast and this
is the first shot of him we get to see.
He was just upgraded to a regular cast member
for season 5, much to the chagrin of ser friendzone.
8 - These are the slaves of Mereen.
Remember last season dany had dedicated her
army to abolishing slavery in the major cities.
9 - Stannis and melisandre make ready for
the wall.
Remember last season during the finale stannis
had pledged to take his forces to fight the
white walkers.
10 - Tyrion in peril.
This season is a big turning point for tyrion.
This shot is before the worst of it.
He ends up in a mutual arrangement with the
red viper.
That look on his face is the ‘i think everyone
is trying to kill me face’.
11 - Jaime tries to end the seige of riverrun.
Even after the red wedding, the blackfish
is still alive and pissed that his entire
family was murdered.
12 - Stannis and his army actually sailing
to eastwatch the easternmost part of the wall.
13 - Ser friendzone counsels daneriss about
her new role in mereen.
She wants to get rid of slavery, but it’s
not quite as black and white like when she
liberated the unsullied and the slaves in
yunkai.
So she has to start making deals with people
instead of feeding them to her dragons.
14 - The sons of the harpy attack.
Once daneriss occupies mereen the fighting
doesn’t end.
The sons of the harpy start fighting a shadow
war against her unsullied and the other mercenaries
she comes to rely on.
In the books they’re called the shavepates
and the freedmen.
15 - This is hizdar zo loraq.
He’s a very powerful person in mereen that
dany has to decide whether or not to marry
to end the shadow war and abolish slavery.
As he controls both the sons of the harpy
and the slave trade.
16 - Dany’s voiceover.
She’s talking about giving the mercenaries
of mereen the option of either accepting that
she’s abolishing slavery or they can die.
17 - This is jaime weilding oathkeeper.
It was one of the new valyrian blades made
by melting down ice, Eddard starks huge two
handed greatsword.
It’s the closest thing to a light saber
in a song of ice and fire.
18 - Tyrion on trial.
This is tyrion facing judgement after the
events of the purple wedding feast.
Which I will not utter here.
Let’s just say he’s in deep shit.
19 - Tyrion in jail.
As you can guess, he gets thrown in jail after
the purple wedding feast.
20 - The red viper.
This is our first real shot of pedro pascal
as the red viper.
21 - Eegritte is back, she’s super pissed
and the wildlings have reached the night’s
watch.
Their mission last season was to take the
night’s watch from the other side of the
wall and open the gates so mance rayder could
bring his army of wildlings through.
as seen here.
22 - Jon Snow prepares everyone to fight the
wilding raiding party
23 - This is one of mance’s giants that
we saw pounding posts into the ground with
their bare fists.
You can’t tell the scale from here, but
those gates are huge.
24 - Yara Greyjoy takes her forces to look
for theon.
In the books her name was asha, but they changed
it on the show.
25 - Jaime gets fitted for his golden hand.
Seriously, it’s a hand made out of gold.
26 - Cersei post purple wedding.
27 - This is one of the night’s watch brothers
offering up his baby to the children of the
forest.
It’s what old craster was going to do with
gilly’s baby since it was a boy.
28 - Arya starts to travels east.
29 - Littlefinger and vary’s scrambling
post-purple wedding.
30 - The red viper tries to get help from
tyrion learning the truth about his sister,
murdered wife of rhaegar targaryen.
31 - This is the epic fight between the red
viper and the mountain.
The mountain was recast again.
Just to make him look even bigger and scarier.
32 - Joffrey and margeary at the actual purple
wedding ceremony.
Also one of the biggest scenes they’ve filmed
since the show started.
33 - Jaime with golden hand takes over the
gold cloaks.
Brienne really rubbed off on him, so he starts
trying to be honorable.
34 - Rewind a bunch, this scene is between
jaime and cersei right after he gets back
and before he gets that golden hand.
Chronologically it’s probably a scene from
episode 1.
35 - The night’s watch prepare for the big
battle with the wildlings.
Which you can also see attacking in this next
scene.
36 - more from the purple wedding feast.
notice what that servant is carrying.
It’s very very important.
37 - Looks like theon made it out of that
dungeon, minus a few body parts.
The character’s transformation is very different
from the books.
It looks like he made it to Stannis’s army
en route to the wall.
38 - This is the first good shot of the new
actor playing the mountain.
Yeah, he’s big.
39 - This is melisandre talking to gilly at
the wall.
40 - This is jenyne poole who the lannisters
marry to ramsay snow, she’s pretending to
be arya stark and they’re at winterfell.
Ramsay snow is basically made ruler there.
So they’re probably in eddard starks bedroom
right now.
41 - This is sansa in the eyrie, littlefinger
takes her there after the events of the purple
wedding.
Remember catylin’s sister is the ruler there.
She’s totally nutters.
42 - Arya and the hound are still in the riverlands.
This scene happens before the first shot we
saw of her earlier in the trailer where she
wasn’t with the hound.
43 - Dany addressing the newly freed slaves
from yunkai.
This happens right after the events of the
season 3 finale.
So the trailer is jumping back and forth in
the season 4 timeline.
44 - Tyrion gets thrown in the black cells.
That’s where they threw eddard stark before
he was beheaded in season 1 and tyrion threw
maester pycelle in there during season 2.
45 - Notice the yellow banner.
This is stannis’ army racing to help the
night’s watch fight the wildlings.
Looks like they’ll get there just in time.
I’ll say that the moments I’m looking
forward to most are the battle at the wall
and the purple wedding.
Let me know what you’re most excited to
see.
The trailer kind of implied that we would
see a full sized dragon.
But I’m not going to hold my breath.
This year I’ll be doing special game of
thrones videos for each episode.
I’ll do reviews right after episodes air
and then just like my sherlock videos I’ll
do a q&a video the day after.
I’m also doing a fun game to guess the kill
order.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here to learn about that contest
I’ll be doing every week and click here
for all of my season 4 preview videos.
I’ve done a bunch of videos for each of
the main characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!